I implemented the changes in to do view
Jas and in index.html which is the place
where our templates are now I had to
figure this one out as well so here's
the thought process I went through now
first I knew I had to add the edit
button in the same place as the delete
button so I had to figure out where that
was one way to do that would be to pop
into our developer tools here and take a
look at what that button actually looks
like and if you poke around you'll find
that the button has a class of destroy
so that's what we're looking for
let's close the developer tools here and
let's go look around for something with
a class to destroy here it is right here
inside of the same places before the
item template remember this is the HTML
that is going to represent each one of
our items so that's our X button we want
to have an edit button as well I'm
literally going to copy and paste but
I'm gonna change the class to that class
name that I gave you edit - BTN if I
save this and I go back to the browser
and refresh sure enough now I should
have two buttons and they look exactly
how we want them to look now the only
problem is when I click on the edit
button nothing happens why not well it's
because I haven't wired it up yet so now
that I've tested it and the button shows
up but it doesn't do anything I need to
figure out where is this edit
functionality going to live well think
about it
the Edit functionality already exists it
happens anytime I double click on one of
these items so I need to find where that
happens and maybe consider putting the
click on my little edit button in that
same area so if I poke around it turns
out I'll find that in the to do view jas
if we go over here and scroll down just
a teeny bit this right here is the
events object literal that binds these
things to these functions so how does
this actually work I mean we'll find
edit functionality when we double click
on a label so that seems pretty simple
my guess would be that this is the event
click or double-click this is the CSS
selector
toggle or label and this over here
toggle completed or edit or clear is the
actual functionality if we scroll down
sure enough there is toggle completed
and there is edit it says in the
comments which this view into editing
mode displaying the input field so yes
indeed this is exactly what we want
right here so we have a double click on
label resulting in the edit and we also
want a click event on what well in case
the answer isn't popping out at you
let's think about how that destroy
button works in index dot HTML this
button has a class of destroy when you
click on it something happens so let's
go ahead and take a look and see if we
can figure out how that works when you
click on dot destroy run this function
when you click on the edit button run
this function when you double click on
label run this function now I'm kind of
into eating this just by reading the
code when I first did it I had no idea
if it was actually going to work but
because experimentation is cheap and
there are no high stakes because of our
version control we can always revert our
changes I'm gonna experiment and try it
anyway I'll save it go back to my
browser hit refresh and now if I roll
over and I click sure enough it runs the
Edit functionality I can hit enter to
get back and I can do it with any of
these including these that have not been
checked so that's pretty cool now I can
also confirm this in the documentation
events and then an object literal let's
look that up if we go to backbone.js org
and we scroll down to the area where it
talks about views sure enough right here
at the very top we have backbones view
dot extend events and then inside of
this we've got these various things it
turns out this is indeed where we
specify our declarative events we can
click on this and read even more about
it and understand exactly how it works
right now I'm not going to go into this
but just know that the documentation
does exist and if the documentation ever
fails you
a Google search will actually do very
well as well oftentimes Google searches
will link you more effectively to the
part of the documentation that you need
so once again not a very hard process
the specific details of what code I
wrote that doesn't matter the point is
my thought process figure out what you
need and then be a detective to figure
out where it could best fit in and
lastly be tofu fit your code in as if it
was already there originally make it
look exactly the same
you'll notice I did not put a space
before my colon the reason is because
the code here does not put a space I did
put a space after and again that's
because that's what the code here has
done so I'm just gonna emulate that